bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans sa vous regarde ce
soir Alain finelcot vient nous parler de
son dernier livre pêcheur de perles chez
galimar vous allez le voir c'est sans
doute le plus personnel le plus sensible
de ces ouvrages à partir de 15 citations
qu'il accompagne depuis toujours il
décrit ses élans ses peurs et ses
regrets sur le monde tel qu'il est et
qu'il n'est plus le philosophe
académicien nous rejoint tout à l'heure
dans la deuxème partie mais d'abord
l'actualité parlementaire nous emmène
dans les coulisses des fédérations
sportives c'est un rapport accablant
pour les dirigeants sportifs français
qui a été présenté ce matin par deux
députés il dévoileent les graves
dysfonctionnements qui ont conduit au
silence sur les violences sexuelles dans
le sport 6 mois d'enquête près de 200
auditions 60 recommandations nous en
débattons dans un instant sur ce plateau
enfin nos affranchis ce soir la
politique yel Goose une chronique
spéciale de notre sémiologue Mariette
d'arégrand faitete pour Alain finelcot
vous découvrirez et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée Elsa Mondin Gava voilà pour
le sommaire ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti l'omerta l'omerta dans les
fédérations sportives ce soir et ainsion
silence pointé par les députés on va
donc s'arrêter sur ce rapport au vitriol
sur le fonctionnement des fédérations
publié aujourd'hui 6 mois avant lesg
fruit d'une commission d'enquête il
dénonce l'entre soi la culture du secret
et du mensonge et des défaillances
majeures dans la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles alors que plusieurs
affaires de viol vous le savez ont
défrayé la chronique ces derniers mois
bonsoir Sabrina si bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir vous
êtes député écologiste des haute scène
et c'est vous la rapporteur de cette
commission d'enquête qui a donc remis
son rapport aujourd'hui bonsoir Carl
olive bienvenue député renaissance des
Yvelines vous connaissez bien le milieu
du sport puisque vous avez été longtemps
journaliste sportif bonsoir Emma audu
bonsoir ravi de vous avoir sur ce
plateau vous êtes ancienne athlète de
haut niveau vous intervenez aujourd'hui
sur les violences dans le sport et vous
avez été vous-même victime d'agression
sexuelle en 2014 de la part de votre
entraîneur on en dira sans doute un mot
enfin bonsoir Patrick rou bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
ancien champion d'Europe de judo
félicitations président de l'association
Artémis sport et auteur de cet ouvrage
le revers de nos médailles paru en 2023
chez duno avant de vous laisser la
parole que dit ce rapport bien sûr les
recommandations et puis les auditions
c'est dans le recap de Valérie Bochard
qu'on accueille tout de
suite bonsoir ma chère Valérie bonsoir
myiam bonsoir à tous Alors que disent ce
rapport parlementaire et bien c'est
l'image du jour aujourd'hui Myriam ici à
l'Assemblée les les députés pardon
viennent de finir la course une course
de fond particulièrement éprouvante 6
mois de travail 92 auditions sous
sererment 133 heures d'écoute des
centaines de témoignages d'athlètes de
présidents de fédération mais aussi de
responsables politiqu et bien je vous le
par je vous parle vous l'avez dit de la
commission d'enquête sur les
dysfonctionnements des fédérations
sportives qui a rendu ce matin un
rapport accablant de 260 pages violence
sexuelle et sexiste racisme loi du
silence atteinte à la probité de son
propre aveu ce matin Béatrice Bellami de
s'attendait pas à un tel finish 6 mois
plus tard on
l'écoute notre objectif premier était de
dresser un constat rapidement les
violences sexistes et sexuelles sont
devenues de le cœur de notre travail et
avec gravité certaines auditions étaient
particulièrement marquantes des propos
poignants et forts avec quelques
témoignages particulièrement douloureux
tout cela nous a bien sûr marqué et au
plus profond et parmi les 193 personnes
entendues pour écrire ce rapport parmi
les les témoignages douloureux la
présidente de la commission a tenu à
saluer celui de Sarah abitb la
championne de patinage artistique elle
avait été entendue en septembre dernier
par l'Assemblée et pour être très
précise c'est en libérant sa parole
quelques temps plus tôt c'est en
révélant ses multiples viols au sein de
son club que la commission d'enquête
avait été créée des souvenirs d'une
violence inouie on l'écoute j'en avais
parlé bah notamment au président de mon
club malheureusement ben je avait pas
été entendu c'est-à-dire que ce que
j'avais dit c'était comme si euh je
parlais d'un d'un simple mal de jambes
ou de cuiss ou de genou donc j'avais été
très gentiment remercié alors que je lui
ai dit que cet entraîneur était
dangereux qui m'était arrivé ce qui
m'est arrivé à l'âge de 15 ans et que il
fallait essayer de l'éloigner d'autre
part j'en avais parlé à l'époque hein
encore une fois au ministère et on
m'avait dit qu'il y avait un dossier
mais qu' valait mieux fermer les yeux
c'est justement pour ne plus jamais
fermer les yeux que la commission
d'enquête a donc proposé ce matin des
solutions pour lutter contre toutes les
formes de violence dans le sport 60
recommandations parmi lesquelles la
création d'une autorité administrative
indépendante chargé des questions
éthiques et capable de prononcer des
sanctions financières des moyens
supplémentaires pour la plateforme
signal sport c'est une c'est une
application qui permet justement aux
athlètes de témoigner de déposer un un
témoignage et puis rendre imprescriptibl
les violences sexuelles sur mineurs
alors le rapport s'est aussi penché sur
un autre dossier celui de l'argent très
exactement sur le manque de transparence
sur le manque de contrôle dans les
fédérations sportives qui rappelons-le
Myriam fonctionne aussi avec de l'argent
publique lorsqu'elle n'était que
ministre des Sports Amélie oua casser
avait été elle aussi auditionnée pendant
plus de 3 He elle avait dû justifier son
salaire de 500000 € par an lorsqu'elle
était présidente de la fédération
Française de Tennis ça fait cher le coup
droit et surtout des balles de tennis un
peu molles et puis décorés pour tous les
petits joueurs de tennis dans toutes les
fédérations par manque de moyens mais la
ministre n'est plus à une polémique près
et d'un revers lifté et bien elle a tout
simplement déclaré que ce rapport
parlementaire était militant et
instrumentalisé à des fins politiques
hasard du calendrier le président de la
République présentait il y a quelques
heures ses jeux olympiqu c'est veux
pardon ses vœux olympiques et
paralympique mais pas un mot sur le
rapport en revanche il a promis d'aller
au-delà des gios de poursuivre les
efforts bien après les jeux de paris et
ça tombe bien puisque ce rapport
parlementaire devrait connaître une
traduction législative Amélie oua
Castera avait promis en décembre 2023
elle parlait à l'époque d'une grande loi
cadre sur le sport en espérant qu'elle
ne soit pas mise hors jeu d'ici la fin
des jeux merci beaucoup Valérie brochat
on va parler des recomm tion il y a
beaucoup de propositions mais je
voudrais qu'on s'arrête sur vos mots
pour commencer Sabrina CBI vous dénoncez
dans ce rapport je vous cite des
défaillances systémiques c'est un mot
très fort ce mot de systémique qu'est-ce
qu'il veut dire précisément est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'aucune fédération
sportive n'est parargé dans notre pays
par cette question des violences et des
violences sexuelles dans le sport ça
veut dire qu'aucune fédération n''est
épargné effectivement qu'aucune
discipline sportive n'est épargnée
qu'aucun club ne n'est épargné à travers
le pays ça peut arriver n'importe où
n'importe quand dans n'importe quel
sport pas des sports plus touchés que
d'autresimp sport il y a certains sports
qui sont plus touché que d'autres ce qui
explique aussi cela c'est le fait que
par exemple la Fédération Française de
Football vous avez 2 millions de
licenciés comparé à d'autres fédérations
c'est très important donc forcément vous
allez avoir plus de cas mais la réalité
c'est que toutes les disciplines sont
concernées vous pouvez avoir des cas
dans n'importe quel territoire en France
autre expression et là encore elle est
très forte omerta à tous les étages je
ferme les guillemets euh qui organise ce
silence dans les fédérations et pourquoi
omerta à tous les étages parce que tout
simplement lorsqu'on a auditionné la
multitude d'acteurs dans ce mouvement
sportif en fait chacun se renvoie la
balle ils ne sont jamais responsables de
rien le fait d'avoir démultiplié les
organes du dans le mouvement sportif a
dilué aussi les responsabilités des uns
et des autres vous avez des dirigeants
de fédération qui indiquent mais nous
c'est pas nous on ne sait pas faire on
n' pas de moyen de levier de sanction ou
alors c'est présempptions d'innocence
dans les clubs quand il quand ils
recrutent des éducateurs ou des
entraîneurs qui ont été condamnés
parfois pour des violences sur mineurs
et bien ils indiquent oui mais ce n'est
pas nous la Fédération a autorisé la
licence vous avez de l'autre côté un
ministère qui dit mais les fédérations
ont des pouvoirs elles peuvent agir donc
elles doivent agir mais pas de contrôle
donc cet omerta finalement à tous les
étages c'est aussi la traduction de
victimes qui ne peuvent pas s'exprimer
ou alors quand elles parlent elles ont
elles sont mises à l'écart très souvent
le monde du sport se se protège
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire cet entre soi
dans le monde du du sport bien cette
entre soit on le on le voit moi je je
quand on a fait les auditions on trouve
autant de personnes qui sont dans les
fédérations sportive au ministère que de
personnes qui sont ministèr qui sont
dans les fédérations sportives vous avez
des cadres d'éteint qui deviennent
dirigeants de fédérations Sportiv et
cetera donc en réalité il y a une ogamie
il y a une endogamie alors Emma audu on
va on va revenir he sur tout ce que vous
avez dit mais l'absence d'écoute pas
temp ça c'est c'est fort dans dans tous
les témoignages j'ai voulu parler j'ai
essayé de signaler et et on ne m'a pas
cru on ne m'a pas entendu vous vous
l'avez vécu ça racontez-nous qu'est-ce
que vous avez subi précisément alors en
2014 j'ai subi des agressions sexuelles
de la part d'un entraîneur de l'équipe
de France d'athlétisme donc j'avais 19
ans à l'époque et au final ouis j'étais
majeur une jeune majeure et et en fait
mon histoire elle elle ne fait que
retranscrire celle dont Sarah beitball
parlait tout à l'heure celle de Carine
Moyon de bag d'Isabelle de monjot qui
sont sont ces premières femmes à avoir
parlé et en fait c'est c'est un contexte
qui est très souvent le même donc
c'est-à-dire un contexte de
vulnérabilité donc à ce moment-là j'ai
19 ans je suis à mes premiers
championnats du monde junior euh avec
cet entraîneur qui est dans le dans le
le qui est entraîneur qui est cadre de
de l'équipe de France d'athlétisme et et
en fait je pense qu'il sent à ce
moment-là une forme de vulnérabilité
parce que je suis très stressée je suis
juste avant ma première finale mondiale
et il se permet des gestes qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû qu'il n'aurait jamais
dû avoir et heureusement j'ai une amie
de l'équipe de France qui perçoit
certaines choses et qui est capable
après de me dire que ce que j'ai vécu
c'est pas normal et que je devrais en
parler et c'est ce que je fais et c'est
ce qu'on demande beaucoup aux victimes
on demande de libérer la parole on
demande de s'exprimer vous le faites
dans la foulée vous attendez je le fait
dans la foulée c'est-à-dire que j'envoie
un mail à mon entraîneur de pôle qui
était différent de de cet entraîneur
fédéral pour lui parler des faits en
utilisant pas les termes d'agression
sexuelle parce qu'on est en 2014 on est
encore peu éduqué par rapport par
rapport à tout ça et pour moi le terme
d'agression sexuelle était bien trop
fort c'est quelques années plus tard en
2018 quand je décide de porter plainte
que je me rends compte après le
mouvement meou que c'était bien des des
agressions sexuelles et en fait entre
2014 et
2018 je je m'aperçois que cette
information ce que j'ai délivré est
reste
entre quelques oreilles donc entre les
oreilles de de cet entraîneur mon
entraîneur de pôle pour bien comprendre
quand vous signaler les fait il y a le
signalement dans le monde du sport ce
fameux entraîneur qui n'est pas le même
que votre agresseur et puis il y a la
plainte en justice est-ce qu'on on
éloigne l'entraîneur immédiatement ou
pas est-ce que vous avez continué à être
entraîné par cette personne alors de
2014 à 2018 j'étais totalement encore au
contact de cette personne que ce soit
pendant mes compétitions ou pendant les
stage et c'était forcément très
perturbant c'était très difficile accep
voilà 4 ans c'est c'est très long
jusqu'en 2018 où il y a un anè stage
avec lui et où je n'en peux plus et donc
là je décide de parler une nouvelle fois
et en parlant une nouvelle fois à ma
fédération je m'attends à ce que eux
soient au courant de quelque chose et je
me rends compte que ce ce que j'avais
dit en 2014 n'a pas été pris en
considération puisque l'information
n'était pas remontée dans les instances
de la Fédération Patrick rou je viens
vers vous carlolive dans un instant vous
vous connaissez bien le le sujet vous
avez travaillé dessus et vous êtes un
ancien sportif pour vous le problème se
situe où principalement est-ce que c'est
dans le traitement des signalements
est-ce que c'est au niveau de la
fédération qui n'éloigne pas
suffisamment la personne qui est mise en
cause indépendamment de la justice
est-ce que c'est cet entre soi d'un
milieu qui travaille dans l'état et qui
se retrouve dans les FD comme on dit où
où est le problème s'il fallait le le
nommer précisément alors déjà je pense
que ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le problème n'est pas récent euh moi je
le vois plutôt comme une sorte de
scandale peut-être un scandale d'État
mais qui a été lissé sur des décennies
en réalité scandale d'État oui parce que
dans les années 80- 90 il y avait déjà
des informations et en fait le phénomène
de l'omerta était encore plus terrible
je pense que ce qu'il n'est aujourd'hui
scandale d' ça veut dire que la tutelle
ça veut dire que le ministère des Sports
euh
est faute et
faute pénale c'est-à-dire que il y a des
gens qui sont à la fois dans les
fédérations et dans le ministère des
Sports et comme je l'ai entendu sur une
chaîne hier sont des portes tournantes
c'est-à-dire que en fait ils ont une
sorte de double rôle et moi j'en ai
rencontré dans dans mon parcours
professionnel je sais
JEE oui exactement absolument et donc
d'ailleurs le livre que l'on a publié
est né de ces difficultés là d'une
certaine manière c'est-à-dire que après
un an un an et demi de recueil de parole
on avait transmis déjà entre 20 et 30
signalement au ministère des Sports et
on avait l'impression d'être toujours
devant une sorte de mur de verre et que
les choses n'avançaient pas et donc à un
moment donné si vous voulez nous notre
rôle en tant qu'associatif puisqu'on a
aussi créé une association c'est d'aider
les victimes ce qui est aussi le le
grand principe de mon sport d'origine si
vous voulez que j'aime beaucoup le
principe du judo c'est l'entraide et la
prospérité mutuelle c'est sa dimension
un petit peu élevé avec une hauteur de
vue un peu spirituelle je pense que tous
les judoca mais au-delà tous les
sportifs au nom de l'olympisme et des
valeurs humaines que l'on porte devrait
en avoir pour priorité aujourd'hui
d'aider les victimes d'abord et de
performer ensuite alors comment les
aider on va venir aux propositions mais
pour terminer le tour de table Carl
olive déjà est-ce que vous êtes surpris
vous connaissez les milieux sportifs
quand Sarah Abitbol a libéré la parole
en racontant son calvaire est-ce que
vous avez été surpris est-ce que il y a
un problème dans les milieux sportifs
est-ce qu'on tolère des choses dans ce
milieu qu'on ne tolère pas dans d'autres
d'abord merci pour pour cette thématique
de de de la soirée parce que je pense
que la parole se libère et et tant mieux
et ma collègue Sabrina sbahi dont je
salue le le travail de l'enquête
parlementaire avec Béatrice Bellami et
là pour pour en
témoigner je pense que les fracture que
nous connaissons dans notre société
depuis des années en matière
d'homophobie en matière de sexisme en
matière d' sexuelle en matière de
racisme elle ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières d'un stade d'un gymnase d'une
d'une piscine on le voit et je vais
revenir bien sûr dans le sport c'est le
coup de projecteur mais que se
passe-t-il sans que on en a beaucoup
beaucoup parler il y a encore quelques
années dans le cinéma que se passe-t-il
dans l'économie que se passe-t-il dans
le monde politique parfois ce que je
constate c'est que d'abord la parole é
tant mieux s libéré avec Mitou Emma Emma
a rappelé Sarah beatball que je connais
également 2000 elle est championne du
monde en 2000 elle a 15 ans Patrick rou
le rappelait 2000 c'est pas 2024 c'est
2000 on parle de il y a 25 ans moi je
pens il y a une particularité dans le
sport je me permets de vous interrompre
c'est que vous avez des jeunes souvent
très jeunes évidemment mineurs au
contact d'adultes 10 15 20 30 ans de
plus les entraîneurs ça c'est spécifique
alors je vais justement venir sur ce
sujetl les deux exemples qui ont été
prisés à juste titre le patinage
artistique et l'athlétisme dont Emma est
une grande championne arrêtez-moi Emma
si c'est d'une bêtise souvent on a des
coachs particuliers on a des coach on
est seul avec l'adulte ça a été le cas
de Sarah bitb avec Stéphan Bernadis ça a
été le cas d'Emma audu également et donc
il y a une espèce de de main mise mental
psychologique de l'entrisme entre
finalement l'entraîneur et Patrick rou a
certainement dû le connaître également
et je dirais l'athlète qui fait qu'à un
moment donné on est sous sous sous
emprise et finalement personne ne le
sait et là où je pense que effectivement
pour moi il y a deux sujets un
évidemment la volonté vous avez des
fédérations qui ont la volonté de
pouvoir le faire et qui ne se cachent
pas derrière leurs petit doigt et puis
il faut aussi les moyens vous avez des
fédérations Sabrina le rappelait la
Fédération Française de Football 2300000
licenciés a les moyens de mettre des
choses en Huble le président Dialo a mis
effectivement des alertes au sein même
de de la Fédération le CNOSF le Comité
national olympique sportif français a
mis également vous commz déjà à aller
sur le terrain des solutions je je dis
juste simplement que s'il y a pas de
volonté et cette volonté elle doit
évidemment être justifiée par par aussi
derrière des sanctions qui soi prises
quand le délit soit pr alors c'est la
question des fédérations des
fonctionnements des fédérations des
financements des fédérations des
tutelles et des contrôleurs on y vient
mais d'abord avant de parler des
solutions je voudrais qu'on s'arrête sur
au fond le le témoign à choc qui a
bouleversé les les députés de cette
commission d'enquête celui d'Angélique
Cochi regardez les propos ont été
ramassés par héen
Bonduel un jour il m'a plaqué contre le
couloir de en face de sa salle de bain
il m'a embrassé sur la bouche et là ça
m'a fait un choc j'étais j'étais sidéré
ça ça s'est fait en quelques mois en
même pas de TR mois il m'a dit euh c'est
rien et moi j'étais tétanisée 10 minutes
après dans l'ascenseur il m'a réembrassé
et je me suis suis pas opposé
physiquement et là j'ai su que ça allait
être compliqué de m'en sortir et avant
mes 13 ans il m'avait déjà violé
digitalement avec le
pénis et en fait c'est ce que j'ai dit à
la barre c'est assez bizarre et étonnant
de le dire mais je préférais
l'effilation parce que ça me faisait pas
mal à chaque fois il a amené ses ses
victimes à La Baule loin de loin de chez
elle complètement déraciné pour passer à
des stades supérieurs entre guillemets
alors alors moi pendant ces 15 jours là
ça a été les 15 pires jours de ma vie je
il m'a violé trois fois par jour sur le
coup on se rend pas compte de
répercussion que ça va avoir toute notre
vie sur notre construction la seule
chose qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
survivre et voilà j'avais un petit
carnet avec les autographes des joueurs
du PSG parce que j'allais les voir au
Camp des Loges et entre ces feuilles
j'écrivais j'en peux plus il faut que ça
cesse je vais faire que tout s'arrête et
j'ai pensé tellement de fois à me
suicider à chaque fois je me disais
j'avais la peur au ventre en me disant
je peux mourir dans l'heure qui suit ce
sentiment d'insécurité aujourd'hui j'ai
36 ans et je vais mieux que depuis
janvier le jour de mes 14 ans ma mère
m'a offert un nouveau téléphone et je me
suis promis de jamais répondre à son
numéro de téléphone quand il a vu que je
répondais plus il est passé à autre
chose et il a pris une autre victime et
elle s'appelait Astrid et je la
connaissais et ça s'est fait sous mes
yeux
et le plus dur pour moi à vivre c'est de
me dire que je les ai pas sauvé c'est
que j'ai dû faire le choix à 12 ans de
sauver ma famille et de pas les sauver
elle j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à parler
à vra dire je l'aurais peut-être jamais
fait si Astrid en question m'avait pas
appelé à 27 ans en me disant je suis à 4
jours de la prescription moi il m'a
violé et avec une autre victime on pense
que toi aussi est-ce que c'est le cas et
à 27 ans je leur ai dit oui moi aussi
mais je sais pas si je suis prête je
sais pas si je peux le dire à mes
parents je sais pas si je peux changer
comme ça ma vie et donc j'ai mis 3 mois
à réfléchir et je me suis dit bah si
c'est soit il va maintenant soit il va
jamais voilà témoignage bouleversant
révoltant aussi d'une certaine manière
Sabrina cbeille angélique Kochi cette
joueuse de tennis n'a pu parler que 13
ans après les faits c'est la fameuse
amnésie traumatique qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez proposer pour ça alors justement
l'une des recommandations effectivement
du rapport c'est de euh de faire
reconnaître cette amnésie traumatique
pour permettre aux victimes que
lorsqu'elles se rappellent des années
plus tard des agressions qu'elles sont
qu'elles ont subi euh qu'elles puissent
quand même porter plainte même s'il y a
euh dans certains cas déjà prescription
on a pu le voir dans plusieurs affaires
donc euh voilà c'est une possibilité qui
pour donc vous recommandez dans le
rapport
l'imprescriptibilité pour les euh viols
les violences sexuelles commises sur
mineurs c'est bien ça elle est
actuellement j'ai regardé de 20 à 30 ans
ça n'est pas suffisant bien forcé de
constater que non puisque il y a
plusieurs victimes qui se sont souvenus
des fait très longtemps après et qui au
moment où elles ont voulu témoigner ou
au moment où elles ont pu témoigner vous
savez dans il y a quelque chose qu'on a
retrouvé dans dans la plupart des
audition quand on a eu quand on a
auditionné les victimes c'était euh
cette reconstruction qui prend
énormément de temps quand angélique
Kochi dit je vais bien que depuis
janvier on parle de plusieurs années
après Sarah beitbol c'est pareil la
plupart des victimes qu'on a auditionné
elles mettent énormément de temps à se
reconstruire quand elles y arrivent
parce que ce n'est pas toujours le cas
d'accord avec ça parce qu'il y a un gros
débat sur la
prescription c'est l'imprescriptibilité
c'est la la même chose que les crimes
contre l'humanité en France il y a un
droit à l'oubli il y a une difficulté de
preuve aussi et il y a de minant avocats
qui vous disent ça n'est pas possible
d'aller jusque là du point de vue même
de l'éthique du droit vous seriez prêt à
voter un amendement pour rendre
imprescriptible les viols sur en France
sur ces sujets là on peut toujours
trouver des excuses c'est bien de
communiquer sur les solutions et je
pense qu'il y a pas de prix à sauver
effectivement des victimes moi j suis
particulièrement j'y suis
particulièrement favorable la
traçabilité est là on parle
pardonnez-moi l'expression on parle
presque de colcis on parle presque de
colcis quand on ressort comme ça des
années après parce que la mémoire
revient et que la douleur est aussi vive
il faut le dire que voilà les preuves
sont très difficiles à à recueillir
évidemment plus le temps passe plus
c'est compliqué ça c'est une c'est une
évidence mais vous êtes favorable à ça
alors j'avance et je viens à Patrick rou
avec cette idée et on parlait des
fédérations d'une autorité indépendante
pour contrôler et même sanctionner
financièrement alors faut n expliquer
comment ça fonctionn les fédérations
parce que on connait pas on n pas
forcément des des éminents sportifs
autour de cette table qui qui finance
déjà et qui contrôle aujourd'hui alors
avant de répondre à cette question je
voudrais juste confirmer ce qu'a dit
Sabrina s à l'instant nous on vient de
voir un témoignage d'une personne qui a
vécu quelque chose de terrible au début
des années 80 et qui est en train de
reconstruire son histoire en ce moment
vous voyez à quel point cette question
d'
imprescribilité en lien avec le
phénomène d'amnésie traumatique est
importante à à réfléchir et à traiter
alors les fédérations oui alors donc les
fédérations je pense que si on songe à
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour améliorer
en fait pour aller vers une une
reconstruction d'un environnement
éthique qui garantisse la l'intégrité
physique et psychologique des jeunes
athlètes je pense qu'il faut en fait
faire un travail sur le fond
c'est-à-dire sur les croyances et les
représentations des acteurs du sport si
vous voulez actuellement moi ce qui me
pose problème c'est la méthode c'estàd
que tout le monde est vend debout contre
les violences tout le monde essaie de
faire sa part donc ça c'est considérable
mais par contre du point de vue de la
méthode j'ai l'impression que
l'intensité n'y est pas alors la méthode
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
aujourd'hui les ministrre a mis en place
ce qu'elle appelle signal sport c'est
cette plateforme qui peut-être manque de
moyens mais qui permet d'accompagner des
victimes pour leur faire signaler au
moins dans le milieu sportif pour déjà
avant la justice éloigner la personne
mise en cause c'est déjà une chose ça ne
marche pas ça le sport et notamment le
sport de haut niveau ne véhicule pas que
les valeurs qu'on entend dans les
discours si vous voulez aujourd'hui
quand vous écoutez les dirigeants
sportifs et politiques parler du sport
en général c'est toujours l'occasion
d'un grand chapitre sur les valeurs mais
qui a un peu une odeur de catéchisme si
vous voulez ou de de code moral euh
sorte de catalogue en fait donc il y a
une quoi une éducation aux valeurs du
sport son un peu plus incarné un peu
plus ce ce ce que j'évoque en fait
effectivement c'est un processus
d'éducation et euh ça passe bien
évidemment par une prise de conscience à
partir de la réalité des situations on
en a parlé tout à l'heure et non pas à
part à partir de réunion théorique où
des gens se réunissent pour décider
quels sont les bons comportements non il
faut vraiment interroger les situations
telles qu'elles se sont passées ce qui
demande du courage ce qui demande la
reconnaissance et l'accompagnement des
victimes c'est très compliqué à faire
donc là nous parlez quasiment de culture
et de mentalité parce que ce qu'il faut
revisiter c'est la vision des
entraîneurs la vision des dirigeants des
arbitres de tous ces gens qui pensent
que comme on l'a cru pendant des
décennies faut absolument souffrir il
faut qu'il y ait du sang des larmes pour
arriver à la performance
là il y a une confusion si vous voulez
se faire violence euh de son propre
consentement parce que on est entraîné
dans une une spirale positive où de tous
les jours on va vers une forme de
dépassement de soi-même c'est
complètement différent de situation où
des acteurs certains entraîneurs
malheureusement parfois abusent de leur
autorité et là ça devient violent pour
pousser les athlètes en avant et c'est
c'est de cette vision qu'il faut
sortir trs intéress c'est un changement
de PARAD compliqué par Ch compqu plein
de paramètres à mett tant qu'on n'ura
pas fait ça ça restera superficiel et je
crains que on nit pas plus de résultats
que dans d'autres domaines comme les
violences faites aux femmes en général
ou aux enfants dans le cadre de famille
ce sont des sujets complexes donc on
parle de de culture de mentalité
d'éducation vous vous avez une
proposition concrète c'est cette fameuse
autorité indépendante qui pourrait faire
quoi qui fonctionnerait comment qui
serait indépendant du du ministère des
Sports c'est ça l'idée et elle
permettrait quoi de recevoir les
signalement qu'est-ce qu'elle ferait
précisément oui alors effectivement en
fait quand on a je l'ai dit he quand on
a travaillé il y a des
dysfonctionnements en tout cas des
défaillances au niveau du ministère des
sports au niveau des fédérations il y a
une confiance qui est rompue entre les
victimes qui pourraient ou qui
voudraient s'exprimer en tout cas
témoigner des violences qu'elles ont
vécu envers ce mouvement sportif parce
qu'elles n'ont plus confiance en réalité
dans la manière dont les dossiers
seraient traités donc c'est pour séparer
les mondes il faut il faut les séparer
pour deux raisons la première c'est
qu'il faut restaurer cette confiance et
il mettent des moyens parce que
effectivement je pense que la cellule
signal sport qui a été mise en place
elle a le mérite d'exister sauf qu'elle
a deux enfin deux problématiques
majeures la première c'est qu'elle est
méconnue des sportifs eux-mêmes puisquà
l'INSEP les athlètes ne la connaissaient
pas et dans plein d'autres fédérations n
on a auditionné enfin on a fait plus de
92 auditions il y avait même des
dirigeants des fédérations qui ne
connaissaient pas la cellule signal
sport ce qui quand même un problème avec
un peu de moyen et une campagne de
publicité ça pe changer pourquoi vous
dites il faut une autorité indépendante
bien parce que la réalité c'est que si
on veut restaurer la confiance et que
les personnes puissent se sentir libres
de témoigner sans avoir peur de
représail sans qu'on leur dise
finalement tu ne pourras plus faire de
compétition ou alors ils vont être pour
certains qui étaient salariés ils vont
être licenciés parce qu'ils ont osé
s'exprimer et bien il faut permettre à
cette autorité indépendante de
travailler en dehors de ce mouvement
sportif d'ailleurs les dirigeants de
fédération eux-mêmes la réclam cette
autorité indépendant elle ferait quoi
alors elle serait un peu sur le modèle
de ce qui a été créé dans la lutte
contre le dopage dont elle elle
engloberait aussi cette question là elle
intégrerait aussi la C le signale sport
et les objectifs en tout cas qui sont
clairement affichés c'est qu'elle puisse
produire des règles de fonctionnement
publier par exemple les comptes des
fédérations ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui pour la transparence aussi
sur la question des rémunérations et de
l'aspect financier de l'éthique et
sanctionné par dans quel cas précisément
parce que là on n'est pas dans le cas de
la justice ex mais oui mais aujourd'hui
en fait on ne contrôle pas ce qui se
passe dans les fédérations vous avez une
agence nationale du sport qui donne des
subventions aux fédérations sportives
sans aucun contrôle et sans aucune
contrepartie qui vérifie aujourd'hui que
les fédérations font de la formation ou
de de la sensibilisation à la question
des violences sexuelles par exemple
personne en réalité on donne de l'argent
de manière automatique c'est une forme
de chèque en blanc qui est donné aux
fédérations sans contreparti autorité
indépendante de la tutelle pour bien
comprendre auourdui cette autorité elle
pourrait être indépendante sanctionner
le cas échéant des fédérations qui ne
jouent pas le jeu qui ne font pas de
formation qui n'agissent pas sur la
question des violences mais aussi à un
moment travaille aussi sur des objectifs
qui seraient clairement affichés sur la
probité des dirigeants ou d'autres
personnes d'ailleurs qui sont dans ce
milieu sportif et maudu c'est la fin de
ce débat mais ça m'intéresse d'avoir à
tous les deux vos réactions d'accord
avec ces propositions oui tout à fait je
pense que c'est important d'avoir
d'avoir comme ça un organe un organe
indépendant et puis surtout je pense que
c'est important que le mouvement sportif
comprennent que les victimes ont déjà
libéré leurs paroles elles ont déjà
parlé maintenant il faut que le milieu
sportif se mette réellement en
mouvement créer des de réelles
politiques pour que cette parole ne soit
pas ne soit pas vain qu'elle serve
réellement à quelque chose et que les
pratiquants et pratiquantes du mouvement
sportif puissent enfin évoluer dans un
sport sain et respectueux à 6 mois des
Jeux Olympiques carlolive une loi sport
à vous entendre il va falloir légiférer
il y a une loi une loi sport qui va qui
va arriver sur pour créer cette autorité
indépendante fin oui je dis simplement
qu'il faut qu'on soit juste vigilant
parce que aujourd'hui on a 1400 agences
qui sont au cœur du du du système
administratif s'agit pas de créer de de
rempiler pour pour rempiler en revanche
il nous faut quelque choseefficace c'est
vrai que c'est plébisité en revanche je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec ma
collègue lorsqu'elle dit que c'est un
chèque en blanc on doit pouvoir
conditionner on doit pouvoir
conditionner un certain nombre de
subventions avec des items qui sont le
travail dans les quartiers par exemple
le travail de prévention de citoyenneté
le travail effectivement la lutte contre
le conditionner les les aides publiques
de l'État ou des collectivités aux
fédération bon affaire à suivre merci
c'était très intéressant à la fois
d'entendre de vos témoignages et et et
les et les parlementaires sur cette
commission d'enquête merci à vous vous
restez non vous restez pas avec moi on
va accueillir al Finel pardonnez-moi
dans une quinzaine de minutes les
parties pr de nos affranchi la politique
avec Yael Go qui nous livre ce soir son
regard sur le mouvement des agriculteurs
une chronique surprise de Mariette
darégrand pour notre invité et puis quel
est le sujet de bonbon Express ce soir
Elsa Elsa un congrès pour inscrire l'IVG
dans la Constitution avant 8 mars
prochain c'est possible mais c'est pas
certain on verra ça tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord je
vous le dis disait on va accueillir
Alain fin kelcô pour pêcheur de perles
son dernier livre chez galimar le
philosophe a rouvert tous ses carnets de
citations qui lui sont si chers 15
auteurs qui ne le quittent pas et qui
lui ont inspiré l'un de ses essais les
plus intimes sur l'amour sur la mort et
sur le monde tel qu'il va et tel qu'il
ne va pas regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco Pomier interview
juste
après si on vous invite à
l'infinicle c'est c'est parce que pour
vous c'est l'heure du bilan le moment
dites-vous de dresser le bilan contrasté
de votre séjour sur terre je suis un peu
âgé alors peut-être ce livre est-il
testamentaire nous on se contentera de
décliner votre CV alin fininkelcot on ne
vous présente plus philosophe
contemporain écrivain polymiste membre
de l'Académie française familier des
plateaux de télévision et animateur de
l'émission réplique sur France Culture
provocateur en série pour vos dé
intellectuel brillant et iconoclaste
pour vos partisans votre nouvel ouvrage
se veut plus intime pêcheur de perles
référence à ces citations de penseurs
qui vous ont nourri arent toville votre
cher Kundera Nietzsche ou encore les
Vinas des perles qui accompagnent vos
obsessions intellectuelles et que vous
approfondissez dans ce livre à commencer
par l'amour aimer même quand le désir se
fait moins pressant c'est respirer une
peau déposer un baiser sur des lèvres
entrouvertes caresser des formes
s'émerveiller de la grâce d'une épaule
le cœur consiste à dépendre disait
Valérie cette dépendance cette emprise
qui rend fou vous l'avez éprouvé à
l'infinlecot en 1984 lorsque votre
future femme vous plaque anéantie prêt à
tout pour la reconquérir vous éviterez
de justesse la rupture j'avais tout fait
à l'envers j'avais joué carartte sur
table entre l'amour et l'amour propre
j'avais choisi l'amour et je ne m'en
étais pas caché
l'amour mais aussi la peur du temps qui
passe face au coupré inéluctable de la
mort vous confessez vos angoisses la
sénilité la perte de la mémoire alors
vous vous appropriez le vœux de Paul
Ricker être vivant jusqu'à ma mort bien
sûr le grand papa ronchon que vous êtes
n'oublie pas les thèmes qui fâchent la
montée du hoisme le néoéminisme le refus
encore et toujours de se soumettre au
dictat de l'époque pour atténuer votre
nostalgie vous invoquez Paul mcartne
[Musique]
de la mélancolie face au passé vous en
avez àin finlecot mais alors
qu'avons-nous perdu exactement ce soir
notre question va de soi pourquoi cette
nostalgie bonsoir bonsoir Alain finelcot
et merci beaucoup d'être là ce livre
pêcheur de perles chez galimar raisonne
comme souvent avec l'actualité mais pour
ceux qui ne vous ont jamais lu ils
auront en quoi 250 pages une forme de
condensé de la pensée d'Alain finelcot
donc j'incite à le lire on peut dévorer
directement ce livre et ce qui est
nouveau aussi on va en parler c'est que
vous parlez de vous et que vous parlez
sensible vous parlez de votre vie
personnelle de votre expérience la
nostalgie n'est pas un gros mot
pourquoi écoutez la nostalgie c'est
d'abord une
composante de la vie de la condition
humaine ce qui a été ne reviendra pas
donc nous sommes voués à la nostalgie et
la poésie en est le
témoignage Benjamin Oliven m'a fait tout
récemment le cadeau d'une autre citation
d' Bonnefis quel souci y a-t-il dans le
poème sinon de nommer ce qui se perd
voilà et aujourd'h mais on peut être
nostalgique sans être amère bien sûr
mais aujourd'hui la nostalgie est mal
vue et est même criminalisé oh il faut
surtout ne jamais dire c'était mieux
avant si vous voulez on n'a pas le droit
de regarder derrière soi Orphé n'a qu'à
bien se tenir mais pourquoi donc même
des film aussi inoffensif camélie Poulin
ou les enfants du Mara ont été par
telérama qualifié de pééniste mais
pourquoi pénéniste parce que c'est
l'image d'une France d'avant la
diversité une France disons homogène et
on a l'air de regretter cette France là
et donc c'est comme si pointait déjà le
museau de mais vous aime nostalgique
dans dans ce récit et et on apprécie
d'ailleurs que vous puissiez regretter
la langue regretter les conversation au
café on y vient alors ce qu'on a perdu à
vous lire c'est d'abord la civilité la
politesse la courtoisie les bonnes
manières la oé 68 voulaiss s' affranchir
des conventions des contraintes
décravater les existences écrivez-vous
là où on attendait le Cool la brutalité
prend les commandes et les incivilités
pleuvent à l'école contre les policiers
et même dans la rue sous les pavés la
plage est devenue sous les pavés la rage
sur les pavé là oui je vous je vous cite
on en est là vraiment aujourd'hui bah en
tout cas euh
le climat est extrêmement
tendu dans la rue quelquefois si vous
voulez ça se manifeste par des cris des
hurlements les cyclistes se conduisent
eux-mêmes comme des des malautru des
mufles vous dites oui c'est ça ce que
c'est-à-dire que et puis il y a cet in
civilité
silencieuse
de pas silencieuse mais pas forcément
agive du
portable quelqu'un téléphone dans la rue
à côté de vous là vous ne supportez plus
c'est il vous invisibilise un Moot à la
mort il vous fait complètement
disparaître alors vous convoquez le
philosophe Emmanuel Levinas Franco
lituanien avec cette citation avant le
cogito le cogito comme on dit il y a
bonjour j'aimerais que vous nous
l'expliquiez vous dites qu'aujourd'hui
le bonjour est un miracle en péril oui
alors avant le il y a bonjour c'est une
phrase absolument magnifique
bonjour Comme je vous souhaite une bonne
journée bonjour comme la marque de la
priorité d'autrui sur moi et il dit il
dit même
lvinas dans sa recherche de l'intrigue
éthique que il a voulu
évoquer parler décrire un aprèsv
originel aprèsvous monsieur originel
mais revenons à bonjour bonjour
aujourd'hui c'est dans les dans les
messages bonjour remplace les
merveilleux échelonnements de la
correspondance cher Monsieur chère
Madame cher
moriaac cher Camu cher ami ch cher Denis
cher angélique et cetera maintenant il y
en a plus que pour bonjour et ce bonjour
là n'est plus unû un chevalier c'est un
gounafier c'est-à-dire il il ne dit pas
il ne s'adresse pas à l'autre il arrive
il cllaxonne il dit c'est moi que vel il
a
perdu bonjour de l'vinace le bonjour de
nager est un miracle en périle alors ce
que l'on a perdu aussi c'est la
transmission et là c'est Marc bloc que
vous goquez alors c'est moins lumineux
comme citation mais quand même elle est
importante Marc bloc historien le rôle
de l'école est de former les élite sans
acception d'origine ou de fortune du
moment qu'il a cessé d'être une
sélection de classe une
une une école de classe une sélection
s'imposera ce que vous dites c'est que
cette sélection pour Marc bloc elle est
synonyme de méritocratie de démocratie
elle est synonyme de démocratie
d'égalité démocratique bien sûr et pour
vous on y est plus à cause à cause de
beaucoup de choses mais à cause
notamment d'un certain Pierre Bourdieu
oui enfin je vais pas qui voulait
d'ailleurs dans la repréoduction éviter
s'attaquer aux inégalités de naissance
notamment et qui pour vous aboutit avec
d'autres au contraire de cela oui
c'est-à-dire Marc bloc ça il écrit ce
texte en 1943 c'est la victoire des
Alliés est certaine et on se demande
comment reconstruire la France et pour
cela créer une école effectivement
démocratique où le privilège ne joue
plus où la cooptation est en effet
remplacé par la sélection Marc bloc
s'inscrit dans une tradition inaugurée
notamment condoret les peuples libres ne
connaissent pas d'autre moyen de
distinction que les talents ou les
vertus mais évidemment Bourdieu et
passron sont arrivés en 1964 avec un
livre qui a un retentissement énorme les
héritiers c'est Bourdieu a dit mais non
non la sélection ça ne fait pas ça ça ne
choisit pas les meilleurs ça ça choisit
les plus favorisés ceux qui trouvent la
culture dans leur berceau et qui en plus
par l'école sont
t crédité d'être en fait supérieur aux
autres et donc les les privilégiés en
acquè un sentiment de supériorité et les
défavoris se disent qu'il ne valent rien
il dénonce ce qu'il croit être la
cruauté de la sélection dans l'école
l'école a adopté cette critique ce qui
fait qu'elle a marginalisé la culture
générale parce qu'elle favorisait les
favorisé et et ce qui fait qu'elle a sup
la sélection le niveau s'est effondré et
ceux qui en ont le plus souffert c'est
évidemment les élèves les enfants qui
n'ont que l'école pour s'élever voilà
voilà le paradoxe dans lequel nous
sommes pris tout le monde le reconnaî
aujourd'hui alors justement vous avez
écrit avant la conférence de presse
c'est pas pour yéragir mais on y pense
forcément d'Emmanuel Macron et de son
réarmement civique avec sa volonté de
restaurer l'uniforme à l'école et les
cérémonies de remise de diplômes on va
écoutez vous réagissez quand la
République perd ses
rites d'autres rites sont inventés moi
je crois pas du tout que le symbolique
soit vieux jeu nos sociétés sont devenu
un peu liquides et donc faut redonner
des repères des repères par les savoirs
qu'on transmet par l'histoire qu'on
transmet par les valeurs qu'on transmet
pour donner des rendez-vous des Caps de
passage la fin du primaire le brevet des
collèges le baccalauréat les
diplomations c'est pas vieux jeu du tout
Macron fait d'une filme qu'elle cotte
non je ne crois pas mais enfin il est
vrai qu'on avait supprimé la
distribution des prix comme si elle
était stigmatisante il est bon qu'elle
revienne il est bon aussi que alors elle
elle est revenue déjà he beaucoup mais
on revent plus cure soit mise au cœur de
l'école mais le sera-t-elle vraiment
parce que moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le libélé l'intitulé
du nouveau ministère ministère de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sports et des jeux olympiqu al ça ça
vousépile mais c'est-à-dire que on peut
pas mettre sous le même toit la vie avec
la pensée et les jeux du cirque il y a
qu'à rebaptiser le ministère de la
Culture ministère de la culture et de la
Fashion Week c'est pareil on verra si
duent ce ministère plétorique perdure ou
pas je voudrais qu'on parle de l'amour
àin finineelcot parce que vos plus
belles pages sont celles vous en parlez
on vous découvre fébrile
accroexomile quand dans les années 80
celle qui deviendra votre épouse la
grande avocate Sylvie Topalov vous
quitte après une dispute sur
l'interprétation de Mary strip dans le
choix de Sophie vous vous livrez pour la
première fois vraiment vous vous livrez
à l'infinelcot pour explorer certes le
sentiment amoureux mais quand même vous
vous dévoilez comme jamais vous écrivez
l'avoir supplié pour qu'elle revienne
oui enfin
euh cette dispute a été la goutte d'eau
depuis un certain temps elle me trouvait
envahissante
précisément parce que fitbrille et donc
elle préservait son compte à soi je
pompais l'air en quelque sorte et donc
le lendemain matin elle m'annonce au
petit- déjeuner qu'elle me quitte et que
sa décision est irrévocable je suis
effondré j'essaie de la convaincre je
n'y réussis pas je vais voir un ami
écrivain je lui demande quoi faire il me
dit fait le mort elle revi surtout ne la
rappelle pas ne précipite pas vous
faites le contraire pas donc donc je me
précipite dans une galerie pour acheter
un tableau qu'on avait vu ensemble je
casse ma tirlire c'était un un
magnifique violoncel de vidalins je
négocie avec le le galeris pour le
prendre tout de suite il voulait mettre
une pastillle rouge dis non non non je
peux pas et donc je vais le déposer sur
sur son sur le palier au risque qu'il
soit volé il n'a pas été volé elle me
rappelle
mais elle reste ell me disent bon elle
me dit on verra et donc donc là j'ai
attendu quand même je n'ai pas fait le
mort mais j'ai attendu mais 10 jours
après ça n'était pas suffisant pour être
irrévocable manifestement n'était pas
irrévocable elle est revenue et
effectivement je n'ai pas caché mon jeu
j'ai dit voilà je et et c'est très très
beau parce que vous vous parlez beaucoup
de l'admiration comme l'une des
dimensions des composants de l'amour je
vais vous citer parce qu'elle a de la
chance Sylvie topalot vous dites que
vous l'admirez en celle dont j'ai la
chance d'avoir croisé la route j'admire
la franchise du regard l'expressivité
l'audace la modestie la bonté l'élégance
le sérieux la futilité le sérieux dans
la futilité l'art de raconter
l'impossibilité où elle me met de lui
marcher sur les pieds et même autour des
pieds la vivacité dans les prêtoirs le
feu intérieur le goût est perdu pour la
lecture
l'inépuisable curiosité du monde quelle
déclaration oui c'est une déclaration
mais j'essaie d'explorer une dimension
négligé de l'amour négligé aussi bien
parler poètes que par les romanciers qui
est précisément l'admiration et mon
expérience je ne veux pas la donner en
exemple ce qui sera mais elle a ceci
d'intéressant peut-être qu'elle pourrait
s'intituler des illusions perdues non
pas illusions perdues mais d illusions
perdues parce que il faut bien savoir
que les gens de ma génération et ceux
d'après
arrivent dans l'amour
si vous voulez sur la pointe des fier on
se méfie on se méfie on voit les
divorces autour de nous on est convaincu
que laamur de 3 ans ou peut-être 7 ans
mais que l'intensité est incompatible
avec la durée et je suis entré en amour
comme ça aussi et là quelque chose m'est
arrivé c'est-à-dire oui ça s'est pas
produit comme je l'attendais et je je je
prétends aussi que l'amour ne rend pas
tout toujours aveugle il peut ouvrir les
les yeux et la lucidité dans ce cas ne
se confond pas avec le désenchantement
c'est tout l'inverse alors il nous reste
très peu de temps on va accueillir nos
chroniqueurs il y a des pages
magnifiques sur la mort vous racontez
vos angoisses vous racontez la hantie
d'Alzheimer j j'y renvoie il y a des
pages aussi sur la question juive qui
vous rattrape j'y renvoie aussi dernière
question qu'est-ce qui dans cette époque
malgré tout vous chérissez
qu'est-ce que vous aimez que vous voulez
voir grandir d'aujourd'hui ah vous me
prenez vous me prenez au dépourvu mais
moi je ne suis pas malheureux même si je
trouve que
l'époque n n'incite pas à l'optimisme je
pense à cette phrase magnifique de
benjamine la catastrophe c'est lorsque
les choses suivent leur cours et
malheureusement elles suivent leur cours
mais l'histoire n'a pas fait fr dans ma
vie donc j'ai une vie privée et ma vie
privée c'est mes amis
c'est mon fils c'est la femme que j'aime
et donc de
cel féliciter on va garder ça allez
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchi
merci beaucoup Alain felcot nos pêcheurs
de perles chez galimar vous allez voir
ils vont vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de
suite et pardon pour le retard allez de
France Inter l'dit politique de la
matinale et laassémiologue Mariette
d'grand qui a préparé vous allez voir
une chronique spéciale pour vous
instalz-vous on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée c'est Elsa mondingava
qui nous la raconte bonsoir Elsa bonsoir
et on va se demander ce soir si
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution promesse d'Emmanuel Macron
et bien ne serait pas un petit peu plus
compliqué à tenir alors que le projet de
loi est examiné demain dans l'hémicycle
voilà ce que dit le président du Sénat
ce matin matin chez nos confrères de
franceino si l'IVG était menacé
croyez-moi je je me battrai pour qu'il
soit maintenu mais je pense que la
Constitution n'est pas un catalogue de
droits sociaux et sociétaux par
tradition je ne vote pas mais je vous
donne un avis très personnel en
conscience je ne pense que la
Constitution c'est pas ce catalogue là
ah oui là c'est important ce qu'il vient
de dire ça veut dire que la promesse
d'aller au Congrès à Versailles réunir
le Parlement s'éloigne alors avant cela
Miriam un petit rétro planning puisqu'on
le rappelle avant de convoquer un
congrès vous l'avez dit la réunion des
députés et des sénateurs il faut que le
texte soit adopté dans les deux chambres
et dans les mêmes termes à l'Assemblée
c'est demain au Sénat ce sera dans
quelques semaines pour la majorité pas
de panique donc ce n'est pas parce que
Gérard Larcher dit ce matin qu'il y est
opposé que ça peut pas fonctionner on
peut voir rentrer l'IVG dans la
Constitution tout à fait il y a un an
Gérard Larcher était déjà opposé alors
par principe il ne vote pas mais il
était déjà opposé ça n'avait pas empêché
le Sénat alors et bien de changer sa
position et d'adopter la proposition de
loi qui introduisait dans la
Constitution la liberté de recourir à
l'avortement c'est vrai que le Sénat en
février dernier avait adopté un texte
qui faisait entrer l'IVG dans la
Constitution alors rien de neuf sous le
soleil si il y a deux raisons au moins
qui changent un peu la donne la première
c'est que le gouvernement a commis une
maladresse une boulette même selon un
connaisseur du dossier celle d'avoir
annoncé la tenue d'un congrès avant même
que les deux chambres votent un texte
commun pas très respect des institution
de quoi piquer les sénateurs et le
premier d'entre eux Gérard Larcher et
puis la deuxième raison et bien c'est
que le gouvernement a choisi de ne pas
reprendre exactement la formulation du
Sénat regardez il y a une bataille
sémantique à l'Assemblée on a voulu
proclamer le droit à l'IVG quant au
Sénat on a préféré la liberté de la
femme de mettre fin à sa grossesse enfin
le gouvernement propose une troisième
rédaction la liberté garantie à la femme
d'avoir recours à une IVG encore faut-il
que la dernière version convienne au
sénateur voilà et c'est dans ce cas et
seulement dans dans ce cas que le
Président de la République pourrait nous
remrer cette image avoir donc son
congrès et symboliquement la semaine du
8 mars Journée des droits des femmes
merci beaucoup Elsa y je me tourne vers
vous ce soir vous vous intéressez aux
réaction à géométrie variale du
gouvernement face aux manifestations au
mobilisation intransigeent vous dites
avec les échos terroristes mais
bienveillant avec les agriculteurs en
temps normal si vous bloquer une
autoroute ou si vous faites sauter un
bâtiment public ce fut le cas la semaine
dernière à Carcassonne il faut vous des
représail combien de fois Emmanuel
Macron a-t-il appelé au retour à l'ordre
face au désordre promis le réarmement
face à la décivilisation de poids de
mesure unzad s'installe près de castre
contre le projet d'autoroute à69 hop on
l'évacue des manifestants envahissent
les terrains où l'on creuse des
mégabacines on les charge et même on
tente de les dissoudre en conseil des
ministres les soulèvements de la terre
rappelez-vous Gérald armanin et Marc
fenau veulent bien parler d'écho mais
jamais d'Agri terrorisme Arnaud Rousseau
de la FNSEA m'a confié hier à quel point
il était surpris par cette cette
bienveillance comme si les agriculteur
avait un permis de manifester et de
bloquer au ministère de l'Intérieur vous
ne trouverez aucune consigne jusqu'à
l'heure actuelle hein au cabinet de
Gérald armanin on vous dit que la ligne
c'est ne pas envoyer de CRS sur des gens
qui souffrent pourquoi cette mensuétude
avec parce que l'exécutif mensuétude
parce que l'exécutif absol n'est pas du
tout en position de force il n'a pas la
main Emmanuel Macron vient de se
relancer avec qu'un gouvernement
commando pour les européennes il a pris
le risque de griller la cartouche
Matignon dès janvier c'est pas pour tout
dilapider en quelques jours gouvernement
qui n'est pas au complet pas encore il
manque des ministres dans des secteurs
clés en crise eux aussi comme le
logement la pêche et l'école avec le
feuilleton en répétition oua casterra et
puis ils ont vu ce qui s'est passé en
Allemagne la réplique outreerin de nos
gilet jaune français la crainte enfin de
l'étincelle de la bavure blindé contre
tracteur c'est inenvisageable après la
mort tragique d'une agricultrice sur la
RN20 hier dans l'Ariège le président a
aussitôt tweeté sa compassion le
problème c'est que ce mouvement sociale
mais le gouvernement dans une situation
pour le moins bancale voire paradoxale
et pourquoi paradoxale par c'est comme
s'il cherchait à canaliser cette colère
en la retournant non pas contre Paris
mais contre Bruxelles en substance c'est
l'Europe techno c'est l'Europe des
normes qui vous met dans le mur c'est
pas nous mais c'est compliqué pour
Renaissance parti qui se dit le plus
européen de France d'accuser l'Europe
comme si les députés renw n'avaient pas
eux aussi validé le Green Deal Emmanuel
Macron défend une écologie pragmatique
populaire simplifié il y a 18 mois il
disait que c'était la fin de l'abondance
pour sortir de la crise va-t-on assister
au grand m à coulepa à la disparition de
ce discours là par peur par peur de
laisser trop de terrain au RN ou à la
droite qui s'en prend aujourd'hui au
parisianisme bobo sacrifier l'exigence
d'une transition pour retomber dans le
productivisme courttermiste ce sera l'un
des renseignement on verra de cette
crise quand elle sera passée et c'est
pas pour tout de suite bon ben on verra
ça je vous regarde et je vais vers vous
Mariette parce que j'aimerais que vous
réagissiez à la chronique de Mariette
dariggrand qui
exceptionnellement nous a proposé et
bien un mot un mot qui n'est pas dans
l'actualité particulièrement puisqueen
général c'est votre mot de la semaine ce
soir vous êtes intéressé au mot du
vocabulaire de notre invité c'est bien
sûr le titre de son émission le mot
réplique voilà alors c'est un mot
médiatique puisqu'il appartient au
médias c'est le titre de de votre
émission que vous vous avez créé que
vous animez chaque semaine à Finkel Crot
et alors souvent quand j'écoute
l'émission j'ai envie de vous poser la
question dans ma tête je me la je vous
la pose et ce soir en direct pourquoi ce
titre ça va très bien avec l'émission
mais vous auriez pu appeler votre
émission et bien je ne sais pas
variation conversation ou bien moire
joli mot de Roland Bart pour désigner la
littérature et ses nuances alors combien
d'hypothèses vous j'ai fait des
hypothèses voilà pour vous poser en vrai
la question première hypothèse vous
allez me dire si c'est vrai ou pas après
première hypothèse c'est pour les
connotation théâtrale que vous aimez ce
mot réplique vous invitez régulièrement
des acteurs je crois que samedi prochain
c'est luukini mais aussi vous vous
organisez un dispositif entre des
personnages et puis il y a ce moment
toujours très passionnant où vous montez
vous-même sur la scène et là c'est vous
qui donnez la réplique à vos invités
donc là peut-être nous dit il doit nous
faire penser que la culture ça passe
aussi à l'écoute à l'oreille deuxième
hypothèse c'est tout à fait autre chose
c'est scientifique même climatologique
c'est quand on dit vous savez un volcan
à des répliques alors ça c'est plutôt
négatif le le sens de de ce motl un peu
plus image Cho non c'est l' image choque
mais justement peut-être que vous avez
voulu Alain
fielcot nous faire une antiphhrase là
nous dire bah non moi chez moi c'est pas
les images médiatiques qui nous font
peur qu'il tourn en bout boucle c'est
tout à fait le contraire c'est-à-dire
des images mentales c'est-à-dire des
idées donc là on va dans le monde des
idées avec vous et la réplique elle est
drement intéressante à ce moment-là
puisqu'il y a une idée puissante comme
un volcan et puis qui peu à peu au fil
du temps réplique réplique et nous
apporte toujours quelque chose de
nouveau là c'est votre philosophe un de
vos philosophes que vous avez d'ailleurs
interviewé Paul Ricker quand il parle de
la refertilisation de notre héritage
donc là vous nous dites quelque chose de
fond ment pour nous-même dans nos vies
aujourd'hui et puis troème hypothèse et
c'est ma préférée parce que elle va au
cœur du langage c'est l'étymologie j'ai
appris en travaillant cette chronique
que rélicaré en latin ça veut dire
replier replier replier replier replier
le linge ou replier le parchemin que
l'on a auparavant déplié pour lire un
texte copieré à la main c'est avant le
livre ça et pour moi dans ma tête je
vois une scène extraordinaire très belle
silencieuse presque monacale et
heureusement vous nous avez mis un peu
de de bac un peu de variation Gén pour
nous dire peut-être que ben oui pour
réfléchir pour imaginer il faut aller
dans ce silence mais en faisant là une
une vivacité bien tempérée entre les
mots et les phrases réaction oh je suis
très impressionné vraiment écoutez il
faut d'abord que je vous avoue que ce
n'est pas moi qui choisi ce titre en
fait moi j'en avais un autre que le
directeur de France culture de l'époque
Jean-Marie borsex a jugé absurde je
voulais appeler ça l'esprit d'escalier
voilà on on revient sur les choses parce
que tout d'un coup on se dit ah on y
avait pas pensé donc il a dit non les
gens vont pas comprendre et il m'a dit
réplique ça aurait pu être conversation
c'est vrai euh l'idée théâtral me plaît
beaucoup et ce que j'aime aussi dans
cette émission et dans cette idée c'est
qu'il y a un
échange parfois vif et que cette
émission et je l'espère un espace de
dialogue o la confrontation pas
seulement la conversation même est
possible parce que aujourd'hui le climat
se durcit énormément dans la vie
intellectuelle vous savez quoi l'INF il
y a les tribunes par exemple tribunon
c'est quand même très très ça vous a
choqué cette pétition contre sa
nomination au Pr surtout c'est d'autant
plus terrible que avant c'est la police
qui faisait la police c'est les
magistrats qui jugeaient les les livres
offensants et cetera maintenant ce sont
les poètes ou des poètes des écrivains
qui font la police contre un écrivain en
plus on accuse d'être identitaire tout
cela est grotesse mais il faut que je me
taise pas du tout je vous propose de
continuer cette conversation en dehors
du plateau parce que le temps qui nous
parti est arrivé à son terme merci
beaucoup merci alin finalc lis pêcheur
de perles sur l'amour sur la mort sur le
monde tel qu'il est et tel qu'il aurait
pu être merci à vous merci les
affranchis à très vite à demain Elsa
très belle soirée documentaire sur LCP
bien sûr à
demain
[Musique]